a weekday a working day but the center
of London is empty as people work from
home to avoid spreading kovat 19 out in
the suburbs it's a different story I
couldn't work without the unsnap
conference calls and emails and
everything
my boyfriend also works at home so both
nothing the same I am working on the
instead not not ideal both of us on it
yeah at the same time especially like
downloading things that plating we
didn't do our job without inspect this
train should be full of people going
about their business but of course it's
not
people have been told to work from home
during the corona virus outbreak and
that's putting a lot of pressure on
digital services that aren't used to
that and already services are struggling
as records of problems compiled by the
down detector website shows there's been
a steep rise in complaints about oh - EE
and Vodafone and about Skype and also
about the popular game fortnight
analysts say the UK's infrastructure
should be able to cope although
emergency measures might be needed this
capacity in the system what's changing
is maybe the patterns and they could be
saying traffic or businesses you know
should be privatized and of say
entertainment and that's something that
has already come from the apprentice the
service provider themselves have
contractual obligations both sumers the
bigger danger is this scams hackers are
launching campaigns attacking people
working from home away from protected
networks this one directs to a page that
looks identical to Microsoft work
software onedrive but will in fact steal
their details and give criminals access
to business data a threat that contains
the promise of the future if anything is
certain in this crisis it's that we'll
all be spending a lot more time online
run a month of Sky News